as a student I am forever mindful of my
budget and due to some recent health
issues I have been making an effort to
fuel my mind and body with healthier
food
however buying items such as fresh fruit
and Lena meat isn't cheap so how can I
use minimalism to buy healthy groceries
was keeping in mind my low budget been
the thing that stands out to me is the
long term cost of not having a a healthy
diet it's right that's one way to think
about it you know add up your here your
health costs farther down the road but
eating good nutritious healthy food
affordably is not it's not hard to do
but there is an intellectual and
educational barrier to overcome meaning
in many cases you need to learn for
example how to grow the most nutritious
vegetables on the face of the planet
sprouts and microgreens that once you
learn it it's like it's as easy as
brushing your teeth and you can do it
anywhere you know what on your on your
patio in your kitchen window doesn't
matter but you have to take the initial
you know couple of hours and YouTube in
your kitchen and learn how to do that
then once you know it that's a skill set
that you have for life you need to learn
the section of the grocery store the
aisle that has things like canned
sardines and anchovies and mackerels and
all these wonderfully affordable but
very nutrient-dense food from the ocean
that that's incredible for DHA it's very
calorie dense it's very satiating for
the appetite you need to learn how to
how to navigate through the produce
section identify the things that are the
dark or the calorie dense or the
nutrient dense foods like your
pomegranates and your avocados and your
purple cabbage and your organic
blueberries and these things that that
are very calorically dense and/or
nutrient dense but that really don't
break the bank like for me I travel a
ton I'm on the road for two to three
weeks out of every month and I just have
my shopping list when I drop into any
city I'm with my uber is on the way to
the hotel
they they pull in to Whole Foods and I
run in there I get my avocados my
sardines my hundred percent dark
chocolates my little seaweed wraps I'll
get a
few different vegetables a little bit of
berries some seeds some nuts I always
call before to the hotel and make sure
they've put a mini-fridge in my room
which most hotels will do if they don't
already have a mini-fridge I get really
good water you know and you can get you
know decent you know local spring water
from just about any grocery store like a
good Whole Foods you bring that all back
and you just feed on that for the whole
week that you're that you're traveling
for example and and yeah that's still
slightly more expensive than going to
Safeway or rosé or Albertsons and
getting a 2% milk in the box of cereal
but it's not significantly expensive
once once you've you figured out how to
how to stare straight ahead like a horse
with blinders and pass by the spirulina
superfood crunchies that cost six bucks
for a bag and like you hunt down the
stuff like I mean avocados and sardines
and and like a bag of raw almonds is not
that expensive and then if you're a home
in your own environment we don't go to
the grocery store that much we have a
few chickens which are dirt cheap and
again we had to learn how to keep the
chickens alive then once we did now we
have eggs for life dirt cheap right we
grow sprouts and microgreens dirt cheap
I've got even like a little girl light
down in my office and you know right now
I'm growing these little berries called
split on it these berries down there and
they're they're wonderful is like this
antibacterial berry they've got this you
know if it's like brushing your teeth
when you eat one but yeah it took me
probably an hour reading you tube going
to Amazon ordering the seeds getting the
pot or putting the dirt in it putting
the seeds in there watering them and
then you know within a month you know
they're growing like wildfire in the
house
you